in the discrete case we saw that we
could recover the PMF of X and the PMF
of Y from the joint PMF indeed the joint
PMF is supposed to contain a complete
probabilistic description of the two
random variables it is their probability
law and any quantity of interest can be
computed if we know the joint things are
similar in the continued setting you can
easily guess the formula through the
standard recipe replace sums by
integrals and replace pmfs by PDFs but a
proof of this formula is actually
instructive so let us start by first
finding the CDF of X the CDF of X is by
definition the probability that the
random variable X takes a value less
than or equal to a certain number little
X and this is the probability of a
particular set that we can visualize on
the two-dimensional plane if here is the
value of little X then we're talking
about the set of all pairs X Y for which
the X component is less than or equal to
a certain number so we need to integrate
over this two-dimensional set the joint
density so it will be a double integral
of the joint density over this
particular two-dimensional set now since
we've used the symbol X here to mean
something specific let us use different
symbols for the dummy variables that we
will use in the integration and we need
to integrate with respect to the two
variables let's say with respect to T
and with respect to s the variable T can
be anything so it ranges from minus
infinity to infinity but the variable s
the first argument ranges from minus
infinity up to
point which is X think of this double
integral has an integral with respect to
the variable s of this complicated
function inside the brackets now to find
the density of X all we need to do is to
differentiate the CDF of X and when we
have an integral of this kind and we
differentiate with respect to the upper
limit of the integration what we are
left with is the integrand that is this
expression here it is an integral with
respect to the second variable and it's
an integral over the entire space from
minus infinity to plus infinity here is
an example the simplest kind of a joint
PDF is a PDF that is constant on a
certain set s and is 0 outside that set
so the overall probability 1 unit of
probability is spread uniformly over
that set because the total volume under
the joint PDF must be equal to 1 the
height of the PDF must be equal to 1
over the area to calculate the
probability of a certain set a we want
to ask how much volume is sitting on top
of that set and because in this case the
PDF is constant we need to take the
height of the PDF times the relevant
area what is the relevant area
well actually the PDF is 0 outside the
set s so the relevant area is only this
part here which is the intersection of
the two sets s and a so the total volume
sitting on top of this little set is
going to be the
basse the area of the base which is the
area of a intersection s times the
height of the PDF at those places now
the height of the PDF is 1 over the area
of s so this is the formula for
calculating the probability of a certain
set a let us now look at a specific
example suppose that we have a uniform
PDF over this particular set s this set
has an area that is equal to 4
it consists of four unit rectangles and
range next to each other so the height
of the joint PDF in this example is
going to be 1/4 it is 1/4 on that set
but of course it's going to be zero
outside that set we can now find the
marginal PDF at some particular X so we
can fix a particular value of x let's
say this one to find the value of the
marginal PDF we need to integrate over Y
along that particular line and the
integral is going to have a contribution
only on that segment on that segment the
value of the joint PDF is 1/4 and we're
integrating over an interval that has a
length of 1 so the integral is going to
be equal to 1/4 but if X is somewhere
around here as we integrate over that
line we integrate a value of 1/4 the
value of the PDF over an interval that
has a length equal to 3 and so the
result turns out to be 3/4 there is a
similar calculation for the marginal PDF
of y for any particular value of little
Y to find the marginal PDF
we integrate along this line the joint
PDF the joint PDF is zero out here it's
nonzero only on that interval and on
that interval it has a value of
one-fourth and the interval has a length
of one so the integral is going to end
up equal to one-fourth but if we were to
take a line somewhere here we integrate
the value of 1/4 over an interval of
length 2 and so the result would be 1/2
so we have recovered from the joint PDF
the marginal PDF of X and also the
marginal PDF of Y